[Musique]
les fête de l'halloween et de noël sont
devenues l'occasion pour des parents de
faire des mauvais coups à leurs enfants
pour les appels point que dans le
langage web et ils ont la cote sur
internet
l'idée a été popularisée en 2011 par
l'animateur de télévision américains
jimmy qui ment il invitait ses
téléspectateurs à faire croire à leurs
enfants qu'ils avaient mangé tous leurs
bonbons d'halloween
puis leur proposer de partager la scène
sur internet
ces vidéos ont fait un malheur
[Musique]
quelques années plus tard pour noël
cette fois l'animateur a récidivé en
demandant aux parents d'en bas les deux
très triste cadeau pour leurs enfants et
de filmer leurs réactions
[Musique]
plusieurs de ces vidéos sur youtube
montre des tout petits qui déballent en
larmes un oignon ou un brocoli devant la
déconfiture et même la panique de
certains enfants
des spectateurs sont très mal à l'aise
et se demande s'il est bien avisés de
rire de son enfant avec nous il y ait
des connu d'autre part en croit plutôt
qu'il est bien de développer le sens de
l'humour dès son plus jeune âge
humour sans conséquence ou blagues
méchantes la ligne peut être mince
inquiet